the the problem is twofold well the
problem is multifaceted but uh
republicans are useless
completely well you know if they gave a
damn they would have done something
about section 230 in the last four years
yeah if they really care you have ted
cruz out there owning
the zuck all the time yeah it's great
it's a great for clips
but what have you done in for you guys
can they they knew they knew they knew
that this was going to happen
and they did literally nothing i am
proud to say that um
of i've made many predictions in my day
and it's usually i always say this says
listen i'm not a prophet i can't pick
lottery numbers it's complicated i make
problems
i make predictions that are wrong all
the time the point is i'll get some
information in front of me and i'll say
wow based on this here's what i think
and then people will clip that'd be like
haha you thought this i'm like yeah
i thought trump was going to win a
landslide back last october with a
record economy
and moody's analytics saying trump was
going to win in in
not necessarily at landslides but he
wins in a landslide without the
lockdowns
yeah right oh yeah easily easily and i
don't think you could find anyone that
could
really argue in good faith against that
i am proud to say i predicted
back in 2018 that republicans were too
stupid
to deal with the issue of censorship to
save their own political party that's
cause they're all a hundred
yeah that's because every one of them
like every one of them is
what's the average age 70 josh hawley
and ted cruz that's it and they're still
in their
60s probably no no no ted cruz is what
his 40s yeah
he's like in his 50s no no isn't he the
zodiac killer though because
he's gotta be in his 60s how old he is
that's uh how old is ted cruz
this is a good time to remember remember
he liked that tweet
he's uh he's 50 he's 50. 49 49 oh he's
not even 15. ted cruz is 49 that's a
rough 49
yeah and uh josh hawley is the i think
josh hawley deserves the most credit on
this
yeah he's missouri he's 40. josh holly's
40.
that's still like i mean considering i'm
not convinced it's stupidity to be
completely honest
i think it's a combination of apathy and
uh look the the the republicans are for
the like
there's there's establishment
politicians dominating both parties and
they always have
and they all hate trump the thing is the
never trumpers
who formed the lincoln project were
free agents essentially political
commentators and you know coordinators
and
strategists or whatever so they had no
problem being like we don't like joe you
know donald trump
but then you get all these republican
candidates actual politicians who are
like i'm up for re-election in two years
uh-oh what do i do i better pretend to
like trump as well yeah but then give
them the opportunity and they're gonna
be like get rid of him
because a lot of those guys didn't they
didn't get punished either there were a
lot of never trump or republicans that
kept their head down and just kind of
pretended to play a ball but you knew
who they were
and they didn't pay the price i mean the
republicans dominated in the
in the senate and house votes i mean
there's 50 open seats or
50 toss-ups and they won every one of
them something like that for 2020
yeah i don't think they they didn't win
every single one but they dominated
whatever it was they didn't they didn't
win them they didn't win the uh
uh the majority i guess i'm just talking
democrats
classified classified a toss-up well
yeah the polls were all broken
yeah yeah but anyway the the point is if
you've got
fervent you've got two you've got two
two kinds of democrats well no you got
three
you've got the corrupt crony leadership
types like schumer nadler
pelosi biden you've got the ultra woke
progressives
who are in my opinion more interested
with celebrity and being angry and
that's like the squad
yeah and then you have the rank and file
or whatever
that's 80 of them right yeah and the
republicans are all the dole whatever
yeah yeah so most most of them are just
like bump like it reminds me of a bunch
of just like
you got a bunch of people walking around
bumping into each other just about like
just mindlessly walking in a room
that's why i want term limits can we get
term limits please
yes i'm sick of having these people
right you know in positions of power for
50 years unchallenged as a gerrymander
and change your religion and never get
out of there
and and and i think they need an
injection you know if you want to make
the term limp for
fine but can we just not have these
people that are in in the senate in the
house for
50 years because they never change i've
heard some good arguments against term
limits one of them we had someone on the
show i remember it was they said
well maybe with sean parnell remember
they said but you need people who are
going to get in
and who are going to sit on committees
and gain seniority and and have
experience
and i'm kind of like yeah you can get
that in four terms right yeah you can't
i mean yeah i'm not saying it has to be
two
but i mean i'm also saying there's no
shortage of people that want to get rich
in politics
and most of these people like you point
out are more interested in celebrity
just like reporters are now
did you see that hilarious mike pence
uh press conference the other day where
the reporters are like screaming at the
team
what's going on here and they're just
like what what are you
my favorite is i think it's caitlyn
collins of csun it's like literally a
minute after
after he's gone and then everyone stops
and then just the last minute she goes
you're complicit and ruining democracy
there's like something like that
on twitter oh yeah dude that was one of
the funniest videos ever
mike pence is like goodbye and then they
all start just yelling rabble rabble
rabble yeah yeah pence is
gone and they're like it's like
that that shows you know you know united
said about that that was their death
rattle
yep yeah it was then you know when
people are dying death rattles that
that's the spit and everything in their
throat the gases are escaping so they go
that's what it was without without trump
they're done
well do you think dan was gonna have a
crap about jim acosta no no he's over
he said oh he's gonna write a book he's
gonna write well he did write a book
he'll write another one about how he was
solely responsible for trump getting
distraction
and then that'll be journalism like us
yeah yeah yeah right we're
we're we fight the power we're really
hard-hitting stuff i don't know they
might go after biden
no way you don't think so no way no no
come on i mean look i think
i think we were talking about this
before probably most people would
secretly agree cnn really the bean
counters that cnn wanted trump to win
oh yeah yes there's no doubt about it
and they are going to suffer
ratings oh they're done they att's rep
reportedly wants to sell them
yeah right because they know they're
heat yeah get rid of it get rid of it
quick before we lose value potato yeah i
was watching
i think it was uh i was there was on
market watch so it was like a
non-political
financial site and like att's buried in
debt
cnn is at its all-time high but don't
you think a buyer would know that
like buyers like i'm not buying this
thing you know you mean you milked trump
for four years and now that he's
he's on the way out you want to offload
that crazy no
way wait till they have to report every
every new couf
passing on joe biden see how that goes
for them
well you think they'll lose the tickers
that's how my little it's like on the
side they have like
234 000 deaths and you'll see it go boop
like 235
you can just see i'm like yeah they're
getting all like
you know excited yeah wait two quarters
we'll see what happens with uh with
trump but uh that's that's the other
news
so trump tweeted this out trump tweeted
i want to thank emily murphy at gsa for
her steadfast dedication and loyalty to
our country
she has been harassed threatened and
abused and they do not want to see this
happen to her her family or employees of
the gsa
our case strongly continues we will keep
up the good
fight and i believe we will prevail
nevertheless
in the best interest of our country i am
recommending that emily and her team do
what needs to be done with regard to
initial protocols
and have told my team to do the same so
trump
has opened up transition
it strongly strongly suggests
that trump is is is nearing the end of
uh
of his legal battle in terms of like
viable paths
there there is still some litigation and
we're going to be doing a big show on it
tomorrow tomorrow night
so i'm not going to say out right right
now like i know the media wants everyone
to say just admit it it's over
yeah i mean this is as close as we've
been trump is not
doing well that's as close as you're
going to get to a concession from trump
i think so his concession speech goes
something like this
uh well you know i love this country and
why you know a deeply
flawed voting system cost me and he may
be right but he's not going to come on
concede that's not trump's game no he's
going to be like i won this election
right i won yeah but yeah joe biden is
stealing it and i have no choice
right right i'll see you in 2024. right
yeah right yeah yeah yeah but oh god
please yeah like
when he is if he on his way out the
doors just like we were talking partner
assange oh yeah
and then just say you're running in 2024
even if he doesn't plan on right
you're like i'm coming back and just
don't know for years
trump needs to say he's retiring
completely and then just go silent
for a month you know why every one of
these fake news outlets these media
companies
will be gone and then he comes back with
his own news now
trump tv i'll trump all 24 hours yeah
and then all these other media outlets
are sold and
and you know they laid everybody off and
it's over yeah dude the the founders of
vox there's three two of them left
already they cashed out they they can't
yeah
they're not doing fine they're doing
just fine but they cashed out this was
them
slapping the slots max bet and then
finally they
you know once they were like okay okay
i'm out that's we're gonna get
get our coupon and go to the go to the
lady at the counter and get my money and
leave
yep yep and then yeah that's that's
exactly what's gonna happen to a lot of
the mainstream media you're going to see
a lot of consolidation
especially on the mid-tier stuff i mean
if you look at
i'll even a lot of you know i don't
watch ratings on mainstream television
because
you know no offense lydia but like both
people at this table get more views a
day than
cnn so like i don't know on tv
right well i'm saying like their average
viewership is a couple hundred thousand
no no no no cnns like this this is the
thing cnn and msnbc
in the past couple of months have
they've like they've taken
the the trump sponged and squeezed it
until it turned to dust
okay so their their ratings did really
really improve okay close
close combined we got them beat probably
i mean tucker was getting what 2 million
viewers
5 five million until all right i was
wrong
until fox news turned on the trump legal
battle
well when they started when they it
started when not poor
tucker tucker was being petulant about
not getting
sidney powell i believe yeah and and
when fox news caused airs called arizona
now cur
to be fair correctly at least right now
that rubbed a lot of people the wrong
way because because you know when you
didn't play it no one else did it
appeared in play at the time that pissed
people off
then tucker i feel like
he got a little a little salty that she
was going on newsmax and she wasn't
right
and look she didn't owe him let's say
hypothetically she had the silver bullet
she's not going on tucker carlson to
give him the evidence that's for the
courts
well apparently she did she said she
said she did she said she sent him an
affidavit and offered a mathematical
expert who can talk about
some of the other data that they've
pulled up okay and i guess tucker said
that never happened
so what about that what about that usb
drive of all that evidence that whatever
happened to that weren't people asking
about that
i don't know remember it was like he
received the package and it was open
what happened to that i don't know that
was the hunter biden thing yeah
yeah what up what was that tucker what
is this it's just he was like
he's like you know our curry our
documents went missing and it's like
did you you didn't just email it was it
the only copy
why was that listen listen listen i'm
familiar with
you know operation security and how to
transmit information and sensitive data
and stuff
i i would not send my usb of sensitive
information
over what do you do ups right yes no
usps
i think it went through us no no i think
it was ups was ups yeah
it was they did an investigation i think
and they found it on the floor or
whatever
yeah wait wait wait wait wait hold on
hold on a minute dude super secure
you've got
super top secret documents all of your
evidence on hunter biden
you put it on usb put in a package and
mailed it out through us
through ups you wait what why don't you
just email them
on top of that what if you were gonna do
even that you hire a courier
so that it's like direct point to point
courier or like you said um there's a
million secure
file transfer websites that yeah yeah
like what are you doing
that doesn't make that and then when he
was like we did find them
and now we're dropping the story because
we shouldn't be going after people's
children
yeah dude yeah morally grandstanding
after
there are a lot of people that believe
that he got got that he
you know maybe somebody was like hey
this isn't it but tucker is fox
he he probably is now yeah
was for a long time before him it was um
who's the super right-wing guy
bill o'reilly bill o'reilly yeah but
then he didn't know how the moon no
like you know yeah that was funny it
bill
yeah isn't it really crazy evolution
like from bill o'reilly to be like sun
goes up sun goes down you can't explain
that
no it can't it's magic and they're just
like magnets the guy in his show was
like we explained that 500 years ago
but then you get tucker who's like not
you know
dumb and no he's smiling yeah he's smart
but then yeah
yeah this hunter biden thing was weird
and then so is the sydney powell thing
is weird
yeah that was uncharacteristic of him
the hunter the hunter thing was really
bizarre
because i mean the left-wing media has
zero problems going after don jr
or ivanka trump they have several
problems with that so and what about
this dude
who's getting foot jobs while smoking
you know he's
got a crackpot in his mouth yeah and
he's got like allegedly
there's any chinese listen listen listen
here's a guy who we got a photo of him
with a crack pipe in his mouth
yeah like explicit videos and then when
they call it for joe biden there's
hunter right there on stage with his dad
it's like
dude whoa man yeah like we just saw
photos of this guy and you're gonna act
like none of that happened everything's
okay
this is the creepiest time what about
the email
that the guy literally thanked him for
connecting him with his dad
and they're just like wow there's no
smoking guns sir
oh are you saying the intel is fake you
know you know michael malus
yeah i gotta quote this guy too much
because he's a smart guy huh he said
he thinks that some very bad people got
data on how much
people are willing to accept yep i'd
agree with that think about
the sheer audacity of everything that's
been happening with like
hunter biden and now with all of the all
of the messed up irregularities
and literal evidence of voter fraud i'm
not saying widespread but there is
literal evidence of
sworn affidavits we know what happened
and it's all being ignored and we're
told to shut up and it's like supposed
to do
70 73 million people voted for donald
trump
i'm i could be wrong about this but i i
believe he's the first president
to lose re-election but gain votes can
you
can you i can't live in a world where i
have to accept that joe biden
got significantly more votes than barack
obama
that's crazy yeah i know i can't buy it
and people freaking
loved he was a celebrity
i think obama was the first to lose
votes and win reelection
like typically when people won he was
running against him i mean that was an
easy dub for him yeah who's voting for
mit and by the
romney is like voting against like a
mannequin yeah he was like a super rich
trust fund kid
he was like republican.txt yeah i
hate it like i hated him and he's also a
total turncoat too he's like
we should prosecute trump and blah blah
blah like get out of here mitt
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you